hallo euch allen zu ZD heute live toll
dass ihr mit dabei seid wir schauen wie
jeden Donnerstag in die Ukraine Monat 20
läuft im russischen Angriffskrieg und es
könnten ja sollten noch viele Monate
Folgen zumindest stellt sich das so
Vladimir Putin vor sagt unser heutiger
Gast der
Militärexperte Gustav gressel vom
European Council on Foreign Affairs wir
wollen deshalb bei ZDF heute live Fragen
spielt Putin tatsächlich auf Zeit ist
das seine militärische Strategie welche
Hinweise gibt es aktuell dafür und
welchen Nutzen hätte das für Russland
gleichzeitig wollen wir heute in die
Ostukraine blicken vor zwei Wochen hat
die russische Armee mit neuen Angriffen
auf die Ortschaft aufdka begonnen und
mittlerweile so berichten dass
Journalisten ist eine regelrechte
Schlacht Vorort ausgebrochen zwischen
ukrainischen und russischen
Streitkräften es geht da vor allem um
strategisch wichtige Gebiete und ver
bindungskorridore in den Osten des
Landes hat es heute unseren Reporter
Dara Hassan Sade verschlagen mit ihm
wenn wir gleich live aus denpro sprechen
und dazu interessieren uns wie immer
hier bei ZDF heute live eure Fragen eure
Meinungen und Kommentare die schickt ihr
uns gerne über die kommentarpalten oder
auch via Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdfde bevor wir starten
mit unseren Gesprächen wollen wir uns
einen kurzen Überblick verschaffen was
aktuell in der Ostukraine abläuft ich
habe gerade schon gesagt das mutmaßliche
Zentrum momentan des Krieges ist die
Stadt avdevka die meisten Menschen sind
bereits aus der Region geflohen lisabel
schivfera mit einem aktuellen
Überblick der Kampf um aftiivka ist
extrem verlustreich für die russische
Armee doch offenbar gelingen Putins
Truppen weitere Vorstöße in der Nähe der
ostukrainischen Stadt ein ukrainischer
Journalist berichtet entlang eines
eisenbahndamms nördlich von aftijivka
sei ein 1 kilm breiter Streifen
eingenommen damit wächst die Gefahr dass
die ukrainischen Truppen dort
abgeschnitten und eingekesselt
werden wann immer es das Wetter zulässt
setzen sie drohen gegen uns ein sie
sehen jede Bewegung auf den
Zufahrtstraßen und feuern auf alle
Fahrzeuge egal ob es Militärfahrzeuge
sind oder Autos mit
Zivilisten von einst über 30000
Einwohnern sind nur noch etwa 1000 in
der Stadt seit gut zwei Wochen sind sie
Ziel einer neuen russischen Offensive
die Regierung in Kiev hat die
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner aufgefordert
aufdjivka zu
verlassen der soweit aktuelle Bilder aus
dem Osten der Ukraine wir schalten jetzt
nach Berlin ins ZDF Hauptstadtstudio
dort sitzt Gustav gressel der
Militärexperte ein schönen guten Abend
in die Hauptstadt zu Ihnen Herr gressel
schönen guten Abend Herr gressel wir
haben gerade Ausschnitte aus gesehen die
Ostukraine so scheint es momentan
Zentrum des Krieges was beobachten sie
ja russland will in diesem Krieg wieder
in die Offensive kommen
man drückt an mehreren Stellen im Osten
an aber am schwersten sind die Gefechte
oben auf divka
die Stadt schaut natürlich auf der Karte
aus wie eine Wiederholung von bachmut
eine Delle in die in die Front hinein
allerdings ist diese Stadt die seit 2014
kontinuierlich zur Festung ausgebaut
wurde sehr gut verteidigt und
die Geländegegebenheiten sind dort
anders also die Gegend ist flacher die
russischen Truppen verfügen über keine
beherrschenden Höhen wie in der Endphase
der Schlacht und bachmut und deshalb ist
es in den viel schwieriger natürlich
diese Stadt einzunehmen oder vorwärts zu
kommmen zudem haben die Ukrainer
dort die Gegend ähnlich dicht vermient
wie es die Russen zuvor im Süden gemacht
haben und dementsprechend hoch sind die
russischen Verluste mhm ähm Stichwort
Verluste da gibt's schon die erste Frage
von unserem Zuschauer Nobert Kranz sind
Russland diese eigenen hohen Verluste
egal das kann noch nicht so immer so
weitergehen schreibt er gerade aktuell
dazu was schätzen Sie dazu ein ja leider
ist es so dass Russland zumindest im
Materialbereich diese Verluste äh zwar
nicht jeden Tag und jede Woche aber doch
durchhalten kann also Russland etwa man
sich den Bereich der Kampfpanzer über
den wir meisten wissen anschaut dann
produziert Russland etwa 250 Kampfpanzer
neu pro Jahr darüber hinaus wenn etwa
1000 Kampfpanzer verschiedene Typen also
die 72 die80 und die 62 aus Depos
renoviert das sind 1250 Kampfpanzer pro
Jahr schätzungsweise zusammen das ist
schon unter dem was man 2022 verloren
hat aber das ist natürlich
schon eine Hausnummer mit dem man den
Krieg fortsetzen kann das Problem auf
russischer Seite natürlich das ist das
Personal und zwar nicht das die sind
schwer durch Mobilmachung zu rekrutieren
da braucht es lange bis sie ausgebildet
sind da ist Kriegserfahrung natürlich
für deren Qualität enorm wichtig und für
diese Qualität sind solche horren hohen
Verluste wie wir es vor allen Dingen in
der letzten Woche gesehen haben
natürlich abträglich denn mit diesen
Fahrzeugen die wir auf den Videos
gesehen haben sind ja in den meisten
Fällen dann auch die kompletten
Besatzungen mit ausgebrannt speziell in
afdfka geht es laut Berichten um
wichtige verbindungskorridore und
Russland soll hier nach eigenen Angaben
jüngst entlang eines eisenbahndamms
nördlich der Stadt avdfka neue Gebiete
erobert haben da geht's konkret um ein
Gebiet so heißt es von etwa einem
Kilometer breite die Ukraine werrt
täglich neue Angriffe ab
hat aber wohl noch Kontrolle über einen
Korridor bis zu 8 km Breite für jetzt
nicht Militärexperten her wie ist sowas
militärisch einzuschätzen wenn das
russische Ministerium das betont ist
Russland da wieder auf dem Vormarsch
oder ist das nur
Propaganda also 8 km ist relativ breit
wir haben gesehen dass in diesem Krieg
vor allen Dingen in diesem Jahr in
diesem Krieg die Fortschritte von
offensiven sei der russischen Seite im
Osten sei es der ukrainischen Seite im
Süden selten mehrere 100und Meter pro
Tag betreffen dieses 1 km breite Stück
ist etwa nur 200 m tief das heißt auch
wenn man in der Breite von einem
kilomeet vorgestoßen ist in der Tiefe
das heißt auf die 8 km die dieser Brück
die diese Beule unter Anführungszeichen
dick ist hat man nur 200 m gut gemacht
dementsprechend dauert selbst wenn auf
der Karte das natürlich elegant
ausschaut ich Kessel jetzt auf Diek ein
in der Praxis um das umzusetzen dauert
das enorm lang wir müssen uns auf daran
denken die Schlacht um bachmut hat 8
Monate gedauert äh und nur in den
letzten drei Monaten wurde es für die
Ukrainer wirklich eng weil die
Nachschubwege sehr gut einsehbar und
komplett unter russischer feuerkontrolle
standen
das heißt das auf der Karte oder im
Moskauer Generalstab gut aussehende Ziel
auf Diek einzunehmen ist in der Praxis
enorm schwierig hinzu kommt noch dass im
Vergleich zu bachmut wie schon gesagt
diese Gegend viel besser zur
Verteidigung eingerichtet ist mm lassen
Sie uns mal Herr gressel auf die
Südukraine schauen da tut sich jetzt
scheinbar nicht allzu viel einige
Beobachter gehen auch davon aus dass
sich das russische Militär hier bald ein
Stück weit zurückziehen könnte ähnlich
wie in Ron im letzten Jahr
Rückzug halte ich derzeit für weniger
wahrscheinlich man versucht russischer
Seite wieder durch Gegenangriffe gegen
die ukrainischen Spitzen vorzugehen und
die Ukraine zurückzut singen äh das
gelingt auch nicht also an sozusagen an
dem weitesten Vorstoß äh wir sehen hier
die Ortschaft der W äm Nord nördlich
davon gibt es so eine Schnellstraße und
dahinter gleich eine Eisenbahnlinie und
auch entlang dieser Eisenbahnlinie
versuchen
hier Kräfte der siebten
luftlandedivision den Ukrainern in die
Flanke zu fallen auch das gelingt nicht
auch da wie gesagt das schaut auf der
Karte einfacher aus als es im Gelände
dann ist
auf der ukrainischen Seite hat man
diesen Kopf in den letzten Tagen ein
bisschen verbreitert können aber auch da
gilt dasselbe wie für die Russen es ist
schwierig vorwärts zu kommen
Konzentrationen von mechanisierten Gerät
führen zu sehr hohen Verlusten
äh
das hat drei Gründe das eine die
schnelle Anforderung von Artilleriefeuer
über spezielle Apps dafür das zweite die
gute Aufklärung durch drohen jeweils
durch beide Seiten und das dritte das
rasche panzerabfeuer durch leutering
munitions und zum Teil auch
selbstgebaute leuings munitions also
dies diese renndrohnen oder first person
view Drohnen wie man auch immer sie
bezeichnen will all das macht es enorm
schwierig mechanisierte Angriffe
durchzukriegen die Ukrainer greifen
deshalb meistens abgesessen das heißt zu
Fuß an in kleinen
stoßtrups verzichten darauf Panzer und
Schützenpanzer an einem Fleck stark zu
konzentrieren weil das Feuer auf sie
zieht äh auf der russischen Seite
verzichtet man dann nicht drauf aber wir
haben im aftivke dann auch gesehen zu
welchen Verlusten das dann eben führt
wenn man nach klassischer Doktrin
mechanisierten Angriff gegen gut
ausgebaute Stellungen probiert
qualifiziertes Personal ist ein großes
Problem für die Russen haben sie gerade
schon gesagt und das interessiert auch
aktuell unsere Zuschauer wir haben
gleich zwei Fragen dazu ich versuche die
Ihnen direkt mal zusammenzustellen Herr
gressel zum einen von Martin Bayern der
fragt m ob Russland im Südosten der
Ukraine also auch diese Region worüber
wir gerade gesprochen haben können die
Russen da überhaupt noch professionell
ausgebildetes Personal nachliefern
oder lediglich Rekruten ins Feld führen
und Thomas kör fragt werden die Russen
auch Frauen einziehen an die Front
bringen auch das war ja eine Meldung der
letzten
Zeit also im Süden für diese
Gegenangriffe werden normalerweise
erfahrene kampferfahrene
Freiwilligenverbände herangezogen das
betrifft in diesem Fall in erster Linie
falsche mega wir haben auch
Marineinfanterie dort gesehen selbst
speznatzeinheiten also Spezialkräfte
werden dort für infanristische
Gegenangriffe eingesetzt all das zeigt
dass man Probleme hat mit im
qualifizierten Personal mit wirklich
guten Kämpfern auch die falsche mäger
die jetzt hier dienen sind großteils
frisch sind zwar freiwillige aber frisch
trainierte freiwillige das heißt Leute
die nach dem
nach ihrer Absolvierung des whdienstes
im letzten Jahr angeworben wurden
das ist
auf russischer Seite ein Problem ist
natürlich auf ukrainischer Seite auch
ein Problem allerdings hier machen sich
auf russischer Seite die die hohen
personalverluste schon auch bemerkbar
ansonsten werden sehr oft diese
zinheiten das heißt Einheiten die aus
Strafgefangenen äh gebildet werden
eingesetzt an heikelen Frontabschnitten
diese werden in Moskau im Grunde als
verschleißmaterial gesehen also da ist
man
nicht darum bemüht dass da viele Leute
zurückkommen in in einigen Abschnitten
um auf dieka haben wir auch gesehen dass
zum Teil blockeinheiten zum Einsatz
kommen das heißt dass auf Leute die sich
bei dem fehlgeschlagenen Angriff wieder
in die versuchen die vorderen eigenen
Stellungen zurückzuziehen geschossen
wird mm vielen Dank Herr gresse bis
hierhin wir reden gleich noch weiter
über die Komponente Zeit die auch eine
Rolle spielt in diesem Krieg und über
mögliche Strategien und groß offensiven
beider Seiten dazu gibt's viele Fragen
und die könnt ihr uns auch weiterhin
gerne stellen in unseren kommentarpalten
oder auch via Mail wir wollen vorher
noch ganz kurz mal in die Ukraine
schauen und in die Ostukraine schalten
in den nipro steht mein Kollege Dara
Hassan ZAD einen schönen guten Abend zu
dir
Dara ja hallo Dara du warst im Sommer
diesen jahreserst noch vor den Toren
vondka kann man sagen in prukowsk und
hast du D mit den letzten verbliebenen
kann man sagen gesprochen die meisten
Menschen sind ja tatsächlich aus der
Region geflohen und jetzt innerhalb der
letzten Wochen Monate hat sich die
Region stark verändert sicherlich zum
enormen Nachteil der
Ukraine ja es war damals schon
sehr sehr angespannt es gab eigentlich
im Grunde nur noch eine einzige
Organisation die die Menschen mit
humanitären
Gütern versorgt hat und vor allem auch
die vielen streuenden und
zurückgelassenen Haus Tiere es waren
damals schon nur noch wenige tausend
dort und der Helfer sagte mir in brokows
journalistisch sieht ihr eigentlich gar
nicht warum man dainfahren sollte weil
es ist eigentlich eine absolute
Frontstadt und die Menschen die dort
bleiben bleiben wieder besseres Wissen
wieder alle Empfehlungen die Sie
bekommen haben und er führe nur selber
hin weil es seine Heimatstadt ist und er
einige von
diesen Menschen dort die nicht gehen
wollen obwohl es
damals schon unglaublich gefährlich war
versorgen will und er kennt sie halt
persönlich das war seine Motivation die
Gefahr Aufsicht zu nehmen ja die Hilfe
vom Westen die bleibt sehr wichtig für
die Ukraine erst gestern Werte man
wieder russische drohen im Westen des
Landes ab da gab es wohl eine Explosion
nah des Atomkraftwerks kamramelnitzki
verschiedene zivile Einrichtungen sind
da bestchädigt worden Menschen wurden
verletzt und es gab auch eine Explosion
wie gesagt nah des Atomkraftwerks und
das brachte Präsident
einmal mehr dazu eine Ansprache zu
halten mehr Waffenhilfe vom Westen zu
fordern wir können kurz mal reinhören
was er da gestern Nacht gesagt
hat dieser Angriff auf das AKW ist eine
weitere Erinnerung an all unsere Partner
wie wichtig es ist die Luftverteidigung
der Ukraine zu stärken und wie
gefährlich es sein kann wenn Russland
internationale Sanktionen umgehen kann
viele Komponenten in den von russischen
Terroristen verwendeten angriffsdrohen
sowie in ihren Raketen stammen aus
verschiedenen Ländern und von
verschiedenen Unternehmen auch aus dem
Westen die Wirksamkeit der Sanktionen
gegen Russland ist buchstäblich auch
eine Verteidigung gegen den
Terrorismus soweit Präsident selenski
aus der letzten Nacht mit seiner
Ansprache er hat ja heute erst Dara
wieder sich auch zu den EU Staats und
Regierungschefs geschaltet und diese
Bitte nach mehr Waffen bekräftigt hat
man da vielleicht doch aktuell Angst ein
bisschen vergessen zu werden denn in na
ostrut ja n auch aktuell einen Konflikt
zu
eskalieren also Angst würde ich es nicht
denken denn ähm in der Ukraine und vor
allem auch unter den im Präsidentenbüro
von selenski der ja selber aus einer
jüdischen Familie stammt ist die
Solidarität mit Israel enorm hoch auch
hat die Ukraine selber ja erlebt wie es
ist wenn man plötzlich angegriffen wird
und ähm der Feind
Zivilisten tötet also Angst ist glaube
ich das falsche Wort die Leute die
Politiker in ähm in der Ukraine haben
auch festgestellt dass
ganz schnell und ganz deutlich und
ehrlich von ihren unterstützerstaaten
gerade aus im Westen vor allem voran von
den USA betont würde dass die
ukrainehilfe weitergehe es gab ja auch
Waffenlieferungen seitdem der Israel der
Krieg in Israel stattfindet so auf der
politischen Ebene finden auch weiter die
Treffen statt es ist der
Parlamentspräsident
Reis der Premierminister
ist ja jetzt gestern gerade in Berlin
gewesen auf der Arbeitsebene findet es
statt aber natürlich stellt man hier
fest dass das medial natürlich weniger
aufschlägt dass man nicht mehr die erste
Meldung ist dass man immer weiter
runterrutscht und natürlich sind sind
die Politiker hier auch
Politiker und wissen was Wahlkampf
bedeutet und wenn die nächsten
Wahlkämpfe anstehen in den
unterstützerstaaten und mit harten
Bandagen gefällt gekämpft wird dann kann
man hier schon fürchten dass die Ukraine
das Thema wenn es nicht oben steht dass
es dann vielleicht zum Spielball von
internen Interessen in den einzelnen
Staaten kommen könnte einen kleinen
Vorgeschmack gab es ja jetzt in der
Slowakei bei den letzten Wahlen wir
haben aktuelle Fragen reinbekommen von
unseren Zuschauern Dara also etliche
interessiert aktuell der bevorstehende
Kriegswinter es ist der zweite wie wird
sich aktuell in der Ukraine darauf
vorbereitet oh dieor bereitungen laufen
wirklich hoch konzentriert und gut
organisiert man hat die Erfahrungen vom
letzten Winter und man hat jetzt
Luft Flugabwehr was man ja vor einem
Jahr nicht hatte da waren ja die
Kraftwerke und die Infrastruktur den
russischen Luftangriffen im Endeffekt
schutzlos ausgeliefert das ist jetzt
anders oder das wurde auch strukturiert
gemacht einer der größten privaten
Energieversorger hat ganz systematisch
Ersatzteile besorgt recht
sagt selber rechnet stark damit
getroffen zu werden auch wenn es
Flugabwehr gibt wird es wahrscheinlich
trotzdem dazu kommen dass es
vereinzelnte Einschläge geben wird oder
dass die russische Taktik die sein
könnte
lokale Luft Flugabwehr zu zu überfordern
s dass wenn erst ein Schwarm von drohen
kommt und dann z.B eine ein
Marschflugkörper dass dann das Kraftwerk
schon noch getroffen werden könnte man
rechnet hier mit dem Schlimmsten ich hab
war vor zwei am Anfang der Woche bei
firmrehen die gesagt haben dass sie
versucht haben so viel wie möglich
im Sommer und im frühen Herbst zu
produzieren zu lagern und auch schon
abzut transportieren damit
es wenn Stromausfälle kommen sollten in
in größerer Zahl oder auf über längere
Zeiträume dasmit sie dann schon die
Produkte haben und weiterhin liefern
können ja du hast es gerade gesagt du
bist aktuell in der Ukraine unterwegs
heute auf den Straßen dennipros und da
kannst du vielleicht uns folgende Frage
noch beantworten die uns Mensch auf
Youtube geschrieben hat was will das
Volk denn aktuell noch im 20 kriegsmonat
wollen die Menschen weiterhin Krieg oder
wollen Sie tatsächlich mittlerweile
Kapitulation die Menschen hier wollten
nie ein Krieg sie wurden angegriffen sie
wurden überfallen und das obwohl
sie mehr Abkommen unterzeichnet hatten
unter anderem auch das Budapester
Memorandum indem damals die Schutzmacht
Russland völkerrechtlich bindend
versprach die Integrität des
Territoriums der Ukraine zu schützen
also die Menschen wollen überhaupt kein
Krieg aber sie wissen was ihnen droht
wenn sie kein Krieg führen ihnen droht
eine Gesellschaft wie in Russland
Rechtsfreiheit das ist ein Land das als
soll sich einfach den Marsch noch mal
vor Augen führen was ist damals passiert
eine ein Teil der der russischen Armee
die Wagner Truppen sind gen Moskau
gegangen und haben einfach mal die
abforder die Absetzung eines Ministers
gefordert und dann wurden sie dafür
nicht bestraft nicht vor ein Gericht
gestellt sondern es wurde mit
Weißrussland ein Hinterzimmer Deal
ausgehandelt und am Ende wurde der
Führer getötet als er in einem Flugzeug
saß in so einem Land will hier einfach
niemand leben und deswegen kämpfen sie
und sie würden gerne aufhören wenn Sie
die Sicherheit hätten dass
in ihre Demokratie bleibt doch es ist
nicht der Fall sie müssen kämpfen wenn
sie das wollen und das wissen die
Menschen hier und wenn ich hier auf den
Straßen mit ihnen gesprochen haben wird
schon sehr häufig gesagt dass der Preis
den sie zahlen enorm hoch ist aber sie
wissen auch was der andere Preis ist den
sie bezahlen müssen und das ist die
Situation in denen sich die Ukraine und
vor allem die Ukrainer befinden und ich
hatte vorhin noch die Gelegenheit mit
einem Mitglied der jüdischen
Gemeinschaft hier Gemeinde hier zu
sprechen knpro hat die größte Synagoge
der Ukraine und auch eine der größten
jüdischen Gemeinde sein Gefühl sein
seine Verwandten in Israel befinden sich
im Krieg und er gleichzeitig hier in
knipro jetzt auch schon fast seit Z
Jahren für ihn stellt sich die Frage gar
nicht ob es eine Angst des Vergessens
gibt oder dass der Israel der Ukraine
was wegnimmt sondern er sagt beide
Konflikte haben im Endeffekt
ein Gedankengut h hinten dran stehend
und dagegen
müssen sich beide Seiten wähen das ist
so die Atmosphäre hier unter den
Menschen sie ist ganz klar pro
Verteidigung von Israel weil sie äh
fühlen sich
sie fühlen mit demjenigen der angegriff
wurde aktuelle Einschätzungen
ausführliche Antworten zu unseren
Userfragen live aus denpro war das unser
Reporter Dara Hassan sad Dara vielen
Dank und ja Grüße in die Ostukraine zu
dir danke schön damit schalten wir
zurück nach Berlin zum Militärexperten
Gustav gressel einen schönen guten abend
noch mal in die Hauptstadt Herr gressel
Zeit ist immer wieder ein Stichwort in
diesem Krieg sie sagen Putin hätte ein
Interesse daran auf einen möglichst
langen Krieg zu Z setzen und er weniger
auf schnelle Erfolge warum genau wählt
Putin ihrer Meinung nach diese Taktik
was bringt sie zu der Annahme die hat im
Grunde im April letzten Jahres
eingeschlagen damals wurde klar dass
eine schnelle Niederwerfung der Ukraine
und Austauschen der Regierung nicht im
Bereich der Möglichkeiten der russischen
Armee war man stand zwar im Norden und
man stand im Osten Kiev aber man war
heillos überdehn man konnte die
Hauptstadt nicht einnehmen man hatte die
Truppen nicht dazu andererseit ist
Russland von seinen Maximalforderungen
die Putin in seiner Rede zur
Kriegserklärung oder de facto
Kriegserklärung zu Beginn der
spezialoperation genannt hat nie
abgerückt und das haben lavrov das haben
peskov das haben Putin in allen ihren
Reden und allen ihren Statements immer
wieder bekräftigt dass sie diesen Krieg
militärisch entscheiden wollen wie hat
man da seit ab Krieg geführt man hat in
der Ostukraine angefangen eine
Materialschlacht zu führen und diese
Materialschlacht führt man immer noch
und Putin in einem seiner let letzten
Besuche bei der Rüstungsindustrie hat
auch gesagt wie viel leopardpanzer
produziert denn die Ukraine wie viel
Patriot produziert denn die Ukraine also
man weiß in Russland natürlich dass die
Ukraine von internationaler
Unterstützung abhängig ist wenn man die
ukrainische Armee nicht schnell schlagen
kann wenn man die ukrainische
Bevölkerung nicht schnell einschüchtern
kann dann kann man doch über die Jahre
hinaus die Kosten für diesen Krieg so
hoch trereiben dass der Westen
irgendwann sagt wir haben genug wir
gehen da raus äh das war Putins
auch Putins persönliches Erlebnis gerade
mit vielen amerikanischen Präsidenten er
hat den Abzug aus dem Irak miterlebt der
hat vor diesem Krieg den Abzug der
Amerikaner aus Afghanistan miterlebt und
es ist seine Erfahrung mit dem Westen
wenn der Krieg zu lang dauert und wenn
die Kosten zu hoch werden dann schmeißen
die Westler das Handtuch und er hat ja
noch berechtigte Hoffnung dass Donald
Trump
2024 antreten wird dass er könnte zum
Gewinnen es kann in der Kongresswahl
weiter zu Schwierigkeiten kommen wir
sehen ja jetzt auch die ganzen Probleme
um die Nominierung eines speakers die
Budgetdebatte in den USA alles das macht
die Hilfe für die Ukraine schwierig und
das bestärkt natürlich auch Putin in
seiner Haltung dass es mit Fortdauer des
Krieges leichter wird für ihn noch dazu
wir haben im vorigen Beitrag gesehen
Angriff auf die
Energieinfrastruktur wir haben im Sommer
gesehen der Angriff auf
Infrastruktur Getreide
landwirtschaftliche Produkte und
elektrischer Strom waren die beiden
großen Exportgüter der Ukraine nach
Beginn des Krieges für beides kriegt man
einen guten Weltmarktpreis kriegt die
Wiesen und dementsprechend schaffen die
auch Arbeit beides versucht Russland
schwergewichtsmäßig anzugreifen und
auszuschalten weil damit die
Abhängigkeit der Ukraine auch finanziell
vom Westen steigt alles was die Ukraine
nicht mehr selber zahlen kann jede gran
muss von irgendjemanden anderen bezahlt
werden die Leute in der
Rüstungsindustrie arbeiten ja auch nicht
umsonst und sind auch nicht die Karitas
das heißt hier versucht Russland auch
ganz gezielt die Last für diesen Krieg
von der Ukraine auf den Westen
umzuschultern und hat dann eben mit den
Wahlen in der Slowakei mit den
Schwierigkeiten in den USA mit
Zerwürfnissen sogar mit engem
Verbündeten Polen im im polnischen
Wahlkampf die Hoffnung dass diese
Zerwürfnisse dass die aus im Westen hier
einbricht das ist die gegenwärtige
Strategie das ist auch der Grund warum
Putin nicht von seinen maximalen
Kriegszielen abrückt er hat zurzeit
keinen Grund von diesen abzurücken er
hat zurzeit keinen Grund auf irgendeinen
Waffenstillstand einzugehen weil er sich
ausrechnet dass wenn ein Präsident Trump
wieder ins am kommt der Deal für ih
besser wird und solange zumindest nicht
sicher weiß dass das nicht ist wird
dieser Krieg fortgesetzt das heißt heißt
wir reden von einem Krieg der zumindest
bis zur amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl
im November läuft und wahrscheinlich
äh am ehsten oder am frühesten Mitte
2025 zu einer
reevaluierung der Kriegsziele in
Russland führen will und frühestens dann
wird man in Moskau vielleicht zu
Verhandlungen bereit sein wir bekommen
jede Menge Zuschauer Fragen Herr gresse
ich versuche sie der Reihenfolge nach
abzuarbeiten mit ihnen weil sie gerade
schon das Stichwort Donald Trump gesagt
haben fragt uns ein
Zuschauer was passiert genau wenn Trump
wiedergewählt wird er wird sich ja
sicher nicht in die beiden aktuellen
Krieger
einmischen die USA tragen einen enorm
eine enorm große Last bzw die Hauptlast
in der militärischen Versorgung der
Ukraine
es gibt in der republikanischen Partei
inklusive Donald Trump selber Stimmen
die sagen diese äh diese Ausgaben äh
gehen auf Kosten der amerikanischen
Wirtschaft die können wir uns nicht
leisten die stell stellen wir ein wenn
die USA die militärische Unterstützung
der Ukraine einstellen dann stellt sich
die Frage was machen die Europäer wenn
ich mir anschaue wie eng etwa Kanzler
Scholz immer mit den USA Schritt in
Schritt gehen will muss ich mir dann
natürlich auch die Frage stellen wie
geht es dann mit der deutschen
Waffenlieferung weiter haben die
Europäer den Mum zu sagen okay das ist
aber unser Kontinent hier und auf diesem
Kontinent halten wir die europäische
sicherheitsordnung aufrecht und wir
lassen das Russland nicht durchgeht und
wir springen jetzt ein oder
äh ziehen dann europäische Hauptstädte
auch äh den Schwanz ein und das Problem
ist die Ukraine Rüstungsgüter Munition
äh werden zu 85% importiert aus dem
Ausland aus dem Westen aus den USA oder
aus Europa wenn dieser Strang versiegt
dann hat die ukrainische Armee ein
enormes Problem ich kann jetzt natürlich
nicht sagen was genau passiert was wenn
Donald Trump an die Macht kommt weil ich
nicht in sein Kopf einschauen kann aber
äh nach seinen wortäußerungen zu diesem
Konflikt äh wäre das ein wäre das für
die Ukraine ein enorm negatives Ereignis
und äh wie gesagt ich äh vernehme
derzeit auch keine vernünftige Strategie
oder Planung aus den europäischen
Hauptstädten wie man mit so einem Fall
umgehen sollte oder könnte oder würde
Stichwort Mast Material und Waffen da
fragt Fabian Meer welche Gründe gibt es
dafür dass Europa noch keine
weitreichenden Verträge mit der
Rüstungsindustrie abgeschlossen hat
obwohl Putins Strategie ein langwieriger
abnutzungskrieg sein wird
äh ja es g eigentlich äh da gute
Neuigkeiten aus Berlin ähm wir haben ja
diese Woche die deutsch-ukrainischen
Handels und industrietage gehabt seit
denen
der Minister für strategische Industrie
auch der Premierminister der Ukraine
angerückt war und es gibt äh
weitreichende Verträge mit deutschen
Rüstungsunternehmen auch in der Ukraine
Werke aufzubauen das Problem ist das
dauert Zeit bis in der Ukraine
dementsprechendes rüstungsgü vom Band
rollt dauert das Zeit weil das nicht auf
Sprung geht in Europa hätte man
natürlich auch die Maschinen anwerfen
können man hätte also z
z.B ein leopardpanzer dauert in der
Produktion 3 Jahre wenn man größere
Mengen bestellen würde Boris Pistorius
hat er mal 120 anvisiert das nach
Stellung äh für für mögliche weitere
Lieferungen an die Ukraine äh auch bei
den Schützenpanzern wie gesagt wenn man
mehr auf einmal bestellt dann verkürz
kann man diese diese Lieferzeiten etwas
verkürzen
äh das Problem ist vor 20 Monaten als
dieser Krieg begann wenn man in
Diskussionen mit Politikern und
Entscheidungsträgern diese Frage
aufgeworfen hat dann wurde einem gesagt
der Krieg dauert ja nicht so lange äh
wenn ich Schützenpanzer XY der 2 Jahre
dauert wenn ich den jetzt anfange zu
produzieren dann kriege ich den nicht in
die
Ukraine also das ist viel zu langfristig
das Problem ist wenn wir es damals nicht
gemacht haben haben wir die Fahrzeuge
jetzt nicht und wenn wir erst am Tag der
amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl anfangen
umzudenken und selber zu denken und
eigenständige Produktion hochzufahren
dann sind wir halt je nach rüstungsgut
in eineinhalb bis zwei Jahren dort wo
wir am Tag der Wahl hätten hinfallen
müssen und das ist das ewige Problem wir
haben Politiker die nicht entscheiden
wollen und auf der anderen Seite haben
wir eine industrielle Lage die eben sehr
frühe weitreichende und weitblickende
Entscheidungen erfordert und das geht
leider nicht vernünftig zusammen schauen
wir noch mal auf die russische Seite
beim Material Thomas K fragt woher
kriegen die Russen überhaupt noch
hochentwickelte elektronische Bauteile
da gab's jetzt auch aktuelle Meldungen
aus Großbritannien dass Russland wohl
mutmaßlich von Nordkorea beliefert wird
was jetzt zumindest Munition angeht da
ist die Rede von 1000 Containern die da
wohl nach Russland gebracht werden das
wird von russischer Seite als unbelegt
abgewiesen aber wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie das dass Nordkorea da als ä
Verbündeter auftritt und Waffen nach
Russland jetzt liefert
das ist sehr wahrscheinlich also es gibt
zum einem mal diese festgestellten
Eisenbahn und Schiffsbewegungen zwischen
Russland und Nordkorea die eben
angesprungen sind das zweite es gibt
zwischen Nordkorea und Russland sehr
weit zurückreichende rüstungsbeziehungen
Nordkorea verwendet Waffen überwiegend
aus sowjetischer Produktion oder
Provenienz bzw Nachbauten von diesen
Waffen die
auf Maschinen nachgebaut wurden die man
aus der ehemaligen Sowjetunion spricht
im heutigen Russland erhalten hat das
heißt diese Beziehungen die früher zwar
unter dem Teppich
passiert ist weil Sanktionen und Ächtung
Nordkoreas für
senantropenwaffenprogramm als als
ungebührend empfinden haben lassen sie
offen zu zelebrieren aber die gab es
früher auch und jetzt durch die
wechselseitigen Besuche kimung in Moskau
lavrov im pyang davor Schoo im pyang ist
diese Beziehung natürlich gestiegen bei
den High-Tech Teilen greift Russland
großteils auf westliche Fabrikate
zurück hier muss man auch sagen dass
Russland bis jetzt keine großen
Anstrengungen unternommen hat etwa viele
westliche elektronische Bauteile durch
esische zu ersetzen sondern setzt auf
schmuckel indem man
Scheinfirmen gründet in
Drittstaaten etwa der Türkei
zentralasiatischen Staaten aber auch
Hongkong und dann über diese
Scheinfirmen diese Geräte importiert und
das ist ein Katz undmausspiel mit den
Nachrichtendiensten des Westens bzw mit
den exportkontrollbehörden des Westens
wann immer die Ukraine eine russische
Rakete abschießt und wir äh Überlebende
Teile haben die man analysieren kann
dann sehen wir welche Baulose das waren
dann können wir aufgrund der Baulose und
der Baunummern zurückverfolgen äh wo
diese wann diese Geräte exportiert
wurden an wen die exportiert wurden und
dann eben die entsprechende Scheinfirma
auf eine Blacklist setzen aber das ist
leider immer ein sehr
reaktives handeln und viele europäische
Staaten muss man auch sagen haben nicht
die nachrichtendienstliche Kapazitäten
so ein Fehlverhalten präventiv
aufzuklären das heißt in den
entsprechenden trickstaaten wirklich zu
schauen was diese Firmen machen die hier
Teile bestellen wo die sind und ob das
mit rechten Dingen zugehen wird oder
nicht mhm der Zuschauer nachtfuchs fragt
welchen Einfluss hätten Kampfflugzeuge
für die ukrainische Armee für das
weitere Vorankommen das kann man auch
vielleicht mit der Frage noch verknüpfen
die Manuel stellt wie wahrscheinlich ist
es dass Deutschland in den nächsten
Monaten noch
taurusmarschflugkörper in die Ukraine
liefert
also Kampfflugzeuge sind für die Ukraine
wichtig in erster Linie weil ihr ihre
bestehende kampfflugzeugflotte schon
enorm abgenützt ist auch diese Flugzeuge
stehen 20 Monate im Kampfeinsatz die
sind ältere Modelle die in Sowjetzeiten
zu Ende des Kalten Krieges produziert
worden sind und dann entweder an
damalige Warschau paktverbündete
gegangen sind die sie mittlerweile an
die Ukraine abgegeben haben oder eben
aus sowjetischen Beständen direkt in der
ine vererbt wurden aber das sind alles
enden wollende Plattformen das zweite
ist die munitionsfrage die meisten
Munitionssorten für diese Kampfflugzeuge
werden in im Russland hergestellt und
nur sehr wenige davon in der Ukraine
selber das heißt sie mit Munition zu
bestücken wird zunehmend schwieriger
weil natürlich auch der Weltmarkt
dementsprechend schon abgegrast ist vor
allen Luft luftraketen jetzt werden
irgendwann F16 kommen auch das sind ter
Baulose von F16 die in den Niederlanden
in Dänemark in Norwegen abgelöst werden
durch
F35 damit ist der Ukraine mal
zumindest sozusagen sicher dass Sie Ihre
abfangeinsätze gegen russische drohen
gegen russische marsflugkörper auch
gegen russische
Kampfflugzeuge fortsetzen wird können
dass sie mit etwa mit amram Raketen
zumindest eine fire und verget Luft
Luftwaffe hat aber dass wir die die
Einsatzmöglichkeiten der ukrainischen
Luftwaffe jetzt nicht dramatisch
verändern im Sinne von Lufthoheit über
dem Süden oder Daub mal russischer
Städte dazu braucht Piloten die anders
ausgebildet werden dazu bräuchte es viel
mehr Flugzeuge mehr einsatzbasen die
Ukraine muss ja aufgrund der russischen
raketenbedrohung ihre Flugzeuge immer
sehr dezentral in kleinen Stücken von
vielen verschiedenen im Land verteilten
Basen starten lassen damit bei einem
eventuell erfolgreichen russischen
Angriff nicht große Teile der eigenen
Luftwaffe ausgeschaltet werden all das
sozusagen macht natürlich nicht
wahrscheinlich dass die Ukraine selbst
wenn sie westliche Flugzeuge bekommt
genauso Luftkrieg führen kann wie etwa
die Amerikaner im Irak nichtsdestotrotz
wichtig ist es zu
Taurus Taus ist für die Ukraine wichtig
weil Taus Bunker angreifen kann also
stark verbunkerte
gefechtsstände Bauwerke die für die
Logistik wichtig sind also Brücken von
der kerschbrücke gefangen bis zu anderen
Eisenbahnbrücken die natürlich
schwieriger auch zu reparieren sind
in dem Sinn wird die Ukraine dran
bleiben an diesem Flugkörper weil sie
den wirklich gerne hätte Taurus ist auch
was die Möglichkeit geht durch russische
Luftverteidigung durchzudringen diese zu
täuschen und zu unterlaufen ein sehr
hochentwickelter und guter marflkörper
das Problem ist aber genau deshalb und
weil es sozusagen die Hauptwaffe
deutscher Abschreckung ist vor allen
Dingen im
Ostseeraum weil Deutschland bis jetzt
noch keine Entscheidung getroffen hat
wie man die Nachfolge von Taurus
organisiert also die Briten und die
Franzosen die ihr marsfelkörper liefern
die haben sich ja schon vor Jahren
entschieden einen Hyperschall Nachfolger
für ihre gegenwärtigen marslugkörper zu
entwickeln Deutschland hat das nicht
getan Deutschland will den Taurus noch
bis in die 2040er Jahre nutzen damit
stellt sich natürlich die Frage was
machen wir wenn wir Taurus an die
Ukraine abgeben was machen wir wenn
dadurch dass die Ukraine Taurus einsetzt
die russische Seite sieht mit welchen
technischen Raffinessen dieser
marchflugkörper umgeht da müsste man
natürlich politischer Seite eine
Entscheidung finden entwickeln wir einen
Taurus 2 einen verbesserten aufgrund der
Einsatzerfahrung in der Ukraine gehen
wir mit den Franzosen und den Briten in
die gemeinsame
marsflkörperentwicklung das wäre
Voraussetzung dafür dass Deutschland den
Taurus liefert und und ja so so stark
wie das Schweigen aus der Politik kommt
scheint man sich hier noch nicht auf
einen Weg nach vorne geeinigt zu haben
mit Blick auf die nächsten Tage Wochen
möchte ich ihn abschließend Herr gressel
die Frage von Gabriel kammerlof Stellen
er fragt wann und wo ist mit einer neuen
größeren Offensive zu rechnen er fragt
explizit nach einer russischen Offensive
aber vielleicht gibt's ja auch Anzeichen
für eine ukrainische Offensive gibt es
Anzeichen wie Truppenkonzentrationen
oder verdeckte
mobilmachungen
äh verdeckte Mobilmachung gibt es in
Russland aber die geht sozusagen auf
diesem unterschwelligen Niveau wie sie
jetzt geht wahrscheinlich weiter die
Ukrainer haben starke Angst dass nach
dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen in Russland im
März nächsten Jahres es zu einer neuen
Teil oder gar generalmobilmachchen kommt
teilmobilmachchen wäre möglich
generalmobilmachchen muss man sagen dass
zumindesten hier die russische Armee
erhebliche Engpässe im Bereich Training
Unterbringung und so weiter hätte man
kann ja in die russische Armee hat bei
der letzten teilmobil machen ihre
ihre Einberufung für den normalen
werrpflicht Turnus verschieben müssen
damit man Kasernen und Ausbilder frei
hat um die Leute zu trainieren die man
mit der Teilmobilmachung ins Feld
schickt das wäre natürlich im nächsten
Jahr
genauso russischer Seite würde ich
denken dass diese offensivtätigkeit aus
dem Osten weitergehen wird und über den
Winter wahrscheinlich noch an inensität
zunehmen wird dafür spricht in erster
Linie das dichte Eisenbahn und
Straßennetzwerk des donbas der als
schwerindustrieregion hier mit
winterfesten Straßen gesegneter ist als
das landwirtschaftliche Süden das zweite
ist das haben wir durch die Angriffe der
Ukraine auf feldflugplätze der
Kampfhubschrauber und in im okkupierten
berdiansk bzw auch auf der okkupierten
Krim gesehen gegen dies diese
Einrichtungen dürfen westliche
Marschflugkörper und ballistische
Raketen eingesetzt werden in rostof am
donn für die direkte Luftunterstützung
der donbas Front kann die russische
Luftwaffe auf Einrichtungen in Russland
selbst zurückgreifen die darf die
Ukraine mit westlichen Waffensystemen ja
nicht angreifen das heißt hier hat man
für die Bereitstellung von
Luftunterstützung russischer Seite einen
Vorteil gegenüber der Angriffsrichtung
im Süden des würde ich würde ich
voraussagen dass die russische
Angriffsrichtungen weitergehen werden
inkremental weitergehen werden im Osten
die Ukraine durchlauft gerade einen
Prozess
die sozusagen offensivtätigkeiten des
Sommers zu analysieren
Lehren daraus zuziiehen Training zu
adaptieren Ausrüstung zu adaptieren um
mit den neuen technischen Gegebenheiten
auf dem Schlachtfeld vor allen Dingen
die drohenproblematik die schnelle
artillerieproblematik die
minenproblematik umzugehen neue
taktische
Vorgehensweisen zu entwickeln und ich
würde denken dass man wahrscheinlich im
nächsten Frühjahr im Süden
wieder mit einer Offensive rechnen
wird weil das Ziel natürlich der Ukraine
die Landverbindungen zur Krim
auseinanderzuschneiden die Krim dann äh
unter fernblockade durch marslkörper und
Drohnen zu nehmen und so ein Faustpfand
in der Hand zu haben die Krim ist ja das
was Putin am wichtigsten ist an seinem
Feldzug in der Ukraine die Putin
ernsthaft zum Verhandlungstisch nicht
gefaked sondern ernsthaft zum
Verhandlungstisch zwingen wird an dem
wird sich ja nichts ändern selbst wenn
man in diesem Jahr nicht so weit
gekommen ist wie man sich es erhofft hat
heißt das nicht dass das Ziel an sich
aufgegeben wird und aus denselben
Gründen wie ich ja vorher für Russland
erklärt hat dass es im Osten einfacher
ist Krieg zu führen ist es für die
Ukraine besser im Süden Krieg zu führen
weil sie die russische Tiefe hier
uneingeschränkt mit westlichen
Fernwaffen angreifen kann sagt der
Militärexperte Gustav gressel Herr
gressel vielen Dank für das Gespräch
danke nach Berlin vielen herzlichen
Dank ja und damit danke auch an euch
wieder für eure zahlreichen Fragen und
für das Interesse das war unser Ukraine
Update für diese Woche auch in der
nächsten Woche werden wir hier bei ZF
heute live wieder über die Ukraine
berichten bis dahin einen schönen Abend
euch allen und bis
bald
ه